welcome to the newshour grain exports
from ukraine are expected to begin in
the next 24 hours 25 million tonnes are
waiting in ukrainian ports where they've
been stuck since russia invaded and
that's caused food shortages and price
rises around the world let's get more of
this from john hendren who's in the city
the port city in fact of odessa so
basically um john if the grain does
leave ukraine it's going to leave from
really where you are
absolutely this is one of three ports
where those grain shipments will be
leaving from and they are where that
grain is being stored right now this is
odessa the first shipments are expected
to go from chernomorsk and then there
would be shipments from pivdeni as well
now there's been an inspection uh site
where uh presumably the russian
officials who can control
some of those areas will will be
inspecting uh those ships but there's
also been a corridor mapped out south
down the coast on the black sea
that is theoretically a safe corridor
but we've seen the the port of odessa
strike uh struck a couple of times i
shouldn't say the port the region of
odessa has been struck a couple of times
and that leaves
some of the farmers who are shipping
this uh grain uncomfortable we talked to
one yesterday in northern ukraine who
said that they were going to store their
grain on site in containers at their
farm because they just don't feel it
safe yet so those first shipments will
really be a test as to whether other
farmers are going to follow suit let's
say john you know areas around odessa
have been targeted it's made the
international community and those
involved in the shipping of grain very
nervous but again there are other areas
of ukraine that have been under
bombardment over the past 24 hours so
bring us up to speed on where we should
be focused here
that's right and i should have mentioned
that 20 million tons of grain are now
sitting at those three ports but you're
right today was a special day here in
ukraine because it was the first day
ukraine was going to celebrate statehood
day and
probably as a link to that
26 rockets were fired from belarus
territory that is of course um in
coordination with russia that's a
russian attack and it struck in northern
ukraine in
we have chicago
learned that there was a power plant
struck in full harris which is in the
dumbass region um and then we have
recently just in the last couple of
hours learned a casualty count from yet
another attack this is one in central
ukraine a rocket attack at krepovnitsky
uh it's in central ukraine and we are
told that five people were killed 25
wounded that's the only one of those
rocket attacks in which we have a
casualty count at this time
john hendren there for us in odessa
thanks very much for the update john
we'll dip in with you through the day
thank you
now a joint coordination center to
monitor grain exports from ukraine
opened in istanbul on wednesday it's
part of that deal where kiev and moscow
signed last week which was brokered by
turkey and the u.n now turkey's defense
minister says it's an example of
international cooperation needed to
tackle global food shortages
ibrahim khalid is spokesman and special
adviser to the turkish president and he
joins me now from istanbul mr clean good
good to have you with us on the program
and thanks very much for your time
one gets the impression that the
situation is still very delicate until
those first ships leave ukraine with the
grain
how concerned is the turkish president
about the situation right now
of course the station remains fragile
critical on all sides the war still is
going on but we've been able to broker
this deal in the middle of this war and
we we have concentrated our efforts in
fact on
some kind of a ceasefire agreement
presumably exchange and eventually a
peace agreement
his negotiation process but it's too
early for that of course to happen at
this point but uh at least we have this
agreement whereby both the ukrainian and
russian agricultural products grain
exports will be reaching international
markets
the process has been rather difficult it
took us months of discrete negotiations
from behind the scenes
talks and
meetings to reach this deal and i think
it will remain also rather critical
sensitive as we go along uh with this
process uh but we have urged all sides
both sides that is both the russian and
ukrainian sides to stick to uh the main
principles of the agreement that they
signed last friday here in istanbul uh
in the presence of our president
president erdogan and the secretary
general and uh with uh that unfortunate
incident that happened a day after on
saturday uh we are we are hoping and
that we are reaching out also to both
sides uh that uh you know things will uh
will move on uh smoothly from this point
onward because it's really in the mutual
interest of both countries uh to have
this operation uh flowing and again
there was a great deal of concern that
as you say less than 24 hours after that
agreement was signed on friday we saw
parts of odessa surrounding areas
targeted uh apparently by russian forces
how much of the president or how much
does the president think that his own
reputation is on the line because when
you underwrite an international
agreement sitting alongside the un
secretary general for something as
delicate as this you really have put
your your reputation uh in the spotlight
and you want both sides to understand
that as well
president erdogan used his own personal
leadership diplomacy to uh make this
deal happen and as i said it took you
know months of negotiations from behind
the scenes and uh in fact if you look at
the
the process
of what happened what unfolded uh over
the last five six months since this war
started this is actually the first major
agreement uh that will deliver something
on the ground not only for ukraine or
russia but for the international
community so i mean in the middle of
this war it's not easy you know to
broker a deal like this and it was
really thanks to president erdogan's
personal leadership skills and diplomacy
and his ability to speak to both the
russian and the ukrainian leadership as
well as to others uh to to make that to
make this happen
of course we are still very much
concerned about the larger picture that
is the war uh that has been going on in
ukraine and we do not condone this war
we do not believe that this is justified
ukraine ukraine's territorial integrity
and sovereignty is critical
and we have to find a way to bring the
parties to the negotiating table and if
you remember in fact the two
major or main meetings that had the
potential uh to lead to a peace
agreement uh were also made possible uh
here in turkey the first one was in
antalya the second one was uh here on
march 29th and in istanbul where the
russian and the ukrainian negotiators
came together
i don't want to sound too optimistic
here but uh in fact this grain agreement
may
lay the foundations and it perhaps built
enough trust
for another round of talks that may lead
to some kind of a ceasefire or peace
talks when you are in the middle of a
war like this it's not easy to have like
a one overarching peace agreement where
everything is on the commitment no it
isn't mr collin if i can just get in
there though but for all of that to
happen as you say it's so delicate you
have to have these merchant ships with
the grain on leaving to show that an
agreement signed i say last friday is
successful and if you agree on things on
small things
dare i say grain shipments are a very
large issue right now but if you can
agree on this sort of an issue then they
can lead to something else but how soon
do you think these shipments are going
to move it's being perhaps muted that
within the next 24 hours might be a
possibility what can you tell us
uh we are talking to the ukrainian side
uh the infrastructure ministry of
ukraine uh i'm sure braco in fact was
here on friday also they are actually
preparing their ships there are a number
of ships loaded already uh they are
getting ready to sail and of course
ukrainian side will provide safety and
security and guidance for those ships in
and around odessa
ports and once they reach international
waters we will take over and we will
monitor it from the joint uh
cooperation uh coordination center uh
here in istanbul so it's really up to uh
both ukraine and russia to get their
ships ready to sail we are ready to
receive them uh there is no imminent
danger of anything of the kind uh at
this point uh if they get ready uh
logistically speaking uh you know
everything um you know can in fact start
flowing uh in the coming days uh by the
way this uh this operation will bring
not only ukrainian grain but also the
russian grain to the international
markets and all together when you put
them together you're talking about close
to 50 million tons of agricultural
products and fertilizers which of course
is very key for global food security so
that's why i said because it's in the
mutual interest of both countries and
the international community and i think
everybody should support this agreement
and uh and address any issues that may
arise there uh together indeed i mean we
know that both grain of fertilizer is
not embargoed or sanctioned in any way
and this was confirmed by several
ambassadors even even last week we want
to reaffirm that for viewers watching
the programme however what hasn't been
cleared up uh and we've asked again and
again several people including the un
secretary general who i interviewed on
friday was if there is an impasse on a
merchant vessel
uh that either ukraine or russia does
not agree with because of whatever
reason how does that impasse get
resolved
if they don't want that merchant ship to
go any further what happens
well we will go step by step the
agreement that was signed last friday
here in istanbul in fact lists a number
of uh articles and actions
when we face a situation like this we
will of course implement you know those
conditions that the provisions require
that both sides to stick only to this
agreement only agricultural products are
carried no other like weapons of any of
any kind will be carried and therefore
there will be a mechanism to inspect
them so there will be an inspection team
here uh and that team will include
representatives from ukraine russia u.n
and turkey uh and therefore we will have
a mechanism here uh the logistic side of
it in fact will uh work as it worked
before the war uh how you know a ship
you know leaves say odessa port or
another port from russia and bleachers
international waters and the black sea
reaches the bosphorus and then from here
goes to its final destination
if there is an issue there are a number
of provisions immediately this uh joint
uh coordination center and
representatives there you know will have
their uh consultations there and of
course we want to make sure that
everything you know goes smoothly but if
there are issues there are mechanisms in
place that will address those issues we
shall see what happens in the coming
hours in the moment ibrahim